so this is dead solid ladies ready let's
go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so you want to make a difference yeah
trust me you're gonna love it
and which bronze are you interested in
joining
I've got a big pilot best in the galaxy
your name
your mission should you choose to accept
it I wonder did you ever choose not to
[Music]
the end form was feared is cream and the
blood will be on your hands the fallout
of all your good intentions you had a
terrible choice to make in Berlin one
life over millions and now the world is
at risk this is the CIA's mission if he
had held on to the plutonium we wouldn't
be having this conversation this team
you'd be dead yes they would
that's the job
[Music]
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away
please don't make me cuts for you how
many times has hunt's governments
betrayed him disavowed him cast him
aside how long before a man like that
has had enough
even though we are
[Music]
so how is he oh you know same always
what the hell is he doing find it best
not to hook
do you remember the first time you saw a
dinosaur thank you we don't really
believe it it's like
America
something's coming it is the t-rex
little come with me you know you can't
stay here
Jurassic world the island
easy girl all of that is in the past
my dad I get kid
I want to show you the future what is
that thing they made it
you need to get us out of here yeah
[Music]
[Music]
look at this world this beautiful world
we built this war together
the world our dreams come true
the world or you can be free
but this world is a lie this world
deserves to die
because this is your world
[Music]
[Music]
we've lived by your promise money
we can save this world
[Music]
we can burn it to the ground
from the ashes demeanor
[Music]
our world possible earthquake here at
the Statue of Liberty looks like you
should have left town a little bit
earlier
[Music]
whatever you doing
stop
[Music]
not many people know what they would die
for that is gonna go make that bacon my
family is trapped 240 floors in the air
this isn't gonna end the way you wanted
to
Hey
that's not a knife that's a knife that's
me
Brian Dundee
[Music]
really yeah really
how'd he keep saying really draw their
might nothing to see here man just get
the clean shade with my my [ __ ] there
see you next week Barry you know when
you dad did it he was he was marking and
well my dad told me about this he was
just like yeah I just came up and he did
they pick any of this okay I just don't
think you can see you from back here not
a lot of Crocs out here huh this is
37,000 miles of pristine beautiful beach
mate
did you know that Australia makes some
of the finest wines in the entire world
no I died I didn't know that
very much
where you hold up this isn't a movie no
it's tourism ad for Australia yes but
listen to you the best Crocodile Dundee
since Crocodile Dundee really yes really
and we had the best trip ever didn't we
it was pretty sweet
[Music]
hey you know there is some great flight
deals with driving right now dude I get
it it's not a movie it's a commercial
[Applause]
no matter who wins
everyone's favorite hero is getting a
new home team
Benji
[Music]
only on
you